accroupis la gouge et la main les
cueilleurs sont à la tâche pour récolter
les asperges blanches
le geste est assise technique il faut
planter la gauche est soulevée
l'aspergent pour la déterrer cette année
là serge et en quantité suffisante
ce sont des belles asperges et son de
beau calibre là ils sont bien blanc
votre question sauvage et puis est-ce
que ce producteur est satisfait de sa
récolte pourtant avec la crise du
coronavirus il y avait quelques
incertitudes au début de la campagne
d'habitude il vend directement sur sa
ferme mais pas cette année la
commercialisation cette année elle est
un peu plus difficile
les gens se déplacent moins sur les
exploitations pour venir chercher pour
acheter des asperges de frêche
donc on a trouvé le moyen de toutes les
petites épiceries du coin
en fait on fournit tout est dit des
petites épiceries du coin qui nous
vendent nos experts en fait les gens se
déplacent quand ils vont faire leurs
cours
en loir et cher la culture de la sptr je
commence à la fin du 19e siècle les
asperges sont à leur destinée au marché
parisien
à partir de 1950 la production va
connaître un long déclin mais il reste
une vraie tradition de la culture
l'aspergent au nord de la loire ont
cultivé en récolte les asperges vertes
cette année aussi elle se vend très bien
la production a été vendue et est vendu
dans les grandes surfaces et chez les
grossistes tout le monde a joué le jeu
en fait ils ont pas apporté de produits
d'espagne ce qui a fait ce qui fait
qu'il n'ya pas eu de problèmes par
rapport à ce qu'on craignait n'y a pas
eu de problèmes d'écoulement de
production l'aspergent est riche en
minéraux et en vitamines blanche ouverte
c'est le moment d'en profiter